some good news for fans of cbs's friday  night lineup tonight the hit drama's  macgyver  uh magnum p i am blue bloods all return  with all new  episodes we're an action show so  it's a banger this year you're going to  see a lot more depth of character so  that's what i'm most excited about  come to know these characters as having  their hearts on their sleeves however  now it's even more so how lucky are we  that we get  such great entertainment like macgyver  and magnum and blue bloods  it's an impactful fun night stay home  with your families and  watch tv yep that's what we're all doing  don't miss tonight's lineup macgyver  kicks off the evening at eight  magnum pi at nine blue bloods at 10 then  of course  8 news now is back at 11